I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormal
[Music]
yes
last question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place she's in the hospital
that's a haunted house
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hard get some rest
[Applause]
hey everybody we finally got our first
look at the New Mutants if you have no
idea what's going on this is Deadpool
x-men universe so this is coming from
Fox but it's a Marvel movie love the use
of the Pink Floyd track in the trailer -
so we'll explain who the team is what
their powers are but I am doing movie
ticket giveaways for a couple of the
movies that are coming up so I'll just
announce a new winner at the end of this
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
this is basically like their first
attempt at doing a genuine horror movie
with these characters and I think that
it's a brilliant idea you don't want it
to look like all those pg-13 x-men
movies and the characters don't lend
themselves to comedy as much as a
character like Deadpool they all follow
from that stranger things vibe which is
kind of funny because the stranger
things trailer for season 2 also dropped
today and there's actually one of the
actors here the person who's playing
cannon ball is actually one of the
actors from stranger things so things
are even more meta than you could
imagine but the direct connection to the
Deadpool movies is is that magic here is
actually colossus younger sister she can
teleport she's a great sorceress so
you're getting into alternate dimensions
you're getting into demons different
planes of existence so because they were
doing these characters it just gave them
the opportunity to do some more horror
elements that they weren't able to do
with the other x-men movies so you're
starting to see the MCU in DC Comics do
this with their movies too where you
have characters that lend themselves to
particular genres and they're just
branching out a little bit so that
everything doesn't wind up looking the
same so I actually think this is gonna
be a legit awesome movie but just based
on the way that it looks it looks like
they're going for a split vibe on you
taylor joy who's playing magic was the
main actress of split which also starred
Professor Xavier in an amazing
performance if you haven't seen that
movie obviously it's not a comic book
movie but it's just legit awesome so
it's getting really meta here we don't
know which other big x-men characters
will pop up during this but I think the
idea is is to keep it relatively
self-contained because of the tone like
you keep Deadpool relatively
self-contained but Deadpool 2 is gonna
have a little bit more crossover with
the mainstream x-men films the new
mutants franchise if it ends up getting
a
sequal looks like it will tie in more
with the Deadpool movies than it will
with the mainstream x-men films but the
whole idea with New Mutants in the
comics is that they're like a very young
version of the x-men team but the team
is Maisie Williams is Wolfsbane
everybody probably recognize her she
doesn't actually turn into a wolf during
the trailer but that's part of her
abilities cannon ball who's the actor
from stranger things that I talked about
you have sunspot and then Mirage in the
actress who's playing this weird creepy
nurse is Cecilia Reyes who's also a
character from the x-men comics so she's
a little bit different from her comic
book persona she's not quite so evil but
they're using her like a nurse ratchet
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest so in
the way that Professor Xavier has Xavier
school where he helps train and take
care of mutants they sort of trade that
for this horror vibe with the insane
asylum so it's sort of a twisted version
of Xavier school where they're studying
them it's a lot more of a down and dirty
Weapon X program so remember no matter
which x-men movie you're in mutants are
bad people hate them they persecute them
they test them they turn them into
weapons like with the Weapon X program
but I think the whole idea here is that
they have to come together inform the
team in order to get out but the only
real notable insane asylums in the
comics are actually the Ravencroft
Institute and that's from the spider-man
comics so that's not where this place is
it looks like it's just some nameless
place that they're pretending is an
insane asylum but secretly it's a place
for them to test on mutants like Cecilia
Reyes asked them in that opening
dialogue do you know up mutants are so
if you're wondering what all those
graves are in the opening montage those
are just the graves of children who have
died as they've experimented on them the
fun really starts when she says did you
know that baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than the adult ones so
obviously all the characters are the
baby rattlesnakes
so if you were hoping for a really
graphic x-men movie I feel like because
this is a horror movie it lends itself
to that kind of gore so think Deadpool
albeit with a slightly more serious tone
the most interesting thing I think
though is is how they will express their
powers and what they'll look like on
screen I think they try to tone it
a little bit but the way they're playing
it like they're pretending this is an
insane asylum so they think that they're
just seeing all these crazy things
happen around them and they can't
explain them till the end of the movie
when they actually legit figure their
powers out and go nuts on everybody but
just going through their powers like I
said magic can teleport she's a
sorceress Wolfsbane
transforms into a wolf-like creature
she's basically like a werewolf sunspot
as the name implies can store solar
energy and give it off so he's like a
big sunburst moon star can create
illusions in play on people's psychic
fears she has a form of psychic energy
and in the comics Cecilia Reyes actually
does have power she can create this bio
generated forcefield but I don't know if
she's gonna be super powered in this
movie that might be a change from the
comics but for the most part even though
they're in this really weird setting
they're relatively true to their comic
book origins in the comics so their
powers the way their characters work
that's all solid but they sort of
transplanted this into a Weapon X type
program where they can just test on them
and find the people that they want to
use but for the most part I'm assuming
that the movie takes place just at the
insane asylum
maybe they break out at the end and
that's where they kind of tell you okay
this is where this is located this is
what's going on with mutants in the
world at this time but they're being
relatively ambiguous about the timeframe
this takes place in just like the
Deadpool movie like you can guess that
that takes place relatively close to
present-day but they're not being quite
so specific like they are with the
mainstream x-men films where they say
okay this is happening around Nixon this
is in the 70s this is happening in the
80s like the Dark Phoenix movie that's
coming up that will take place in the
80s but a lot of these other movies I
think they're just choosing to have a
little bit more fun with and be a little
less on the nose so as the title card
implies this is coming out in April but
obviously because it's a horror movie
they're releasing the trailer during
October the month of Halloween they
release it on Friday the 13th just to
give it that really spooky vibe they
actually drop this at midnight so it was
a little bit weird I had to wait to do
the video for it but let me know in the
comments what do you think about them
doing a legit horror film with Marvel
characters I mean I love some of these
actors and the movies they've been in
before like I'm a big fan of Maisie
Williams and anya taylor joy was a may
using in split but I'm surprised that
they haven't tried this before I think
that's just because the horror genre of
movie is coming back stranger things
help bring that back a little bit and
even though Marvel did movies like Blade
technically that's more of a vampire
genre film not so much straight-up
horror we don't really know if they're
gonna attach a post-credits scene to
this or they're gonna try and tee up
some sequel but obviously being an x-men
Marvel movie
this'll n's itself two sequels so I
think the end of the movie will sort of
give you an idea for where the
characters are headed next because the
whole idea is they form the team during
this first movie then maybe they try to
connect that to Professor Xavier I'll be
posting my non-spoilery thor ragnarok
review next week once the embargo is up
so look out for that my stranger things
trailer will post in a couple hours
congratulations to Devin Andrews you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so while you wait for that you
can click here for brand new Thor
Ragnarok and you can click here for
brand new Star Wars the last Jedi thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight